you're in the flesh a Super Bowl winning
quarterback 13 seasons in the NFL spent
time on the NFL Network and ESPN and
loves to remind Marshall Faulk that he
beat him out for the wack offensive
player here way back in the day Trent
Dilfer good to see you nice ear it's
always fun to be with you that was a
fantastic moment I think that was at the
Super Bowl
I forget which Super Bowl it was where
we were having dinner with Marshall he
still gets bothered if when he listens
he will both get tech the wack you were
for Fresno State I mean I just better
than him I mean you just leave it at
that through the door right now and now
you're part of the new NFL Network
series so land science with what John
Brenkus who's gonna be out here shortly
to join you that'll be an hour number
three but I wanted some one-on-one time
with you first since there's so much
going on here there is a lot you are the
perfect person to ask about this because
last time you were on the show on the
phone and you talked about how Josh
Rosen has done a a 180 okay that he has
totally changed in it that it seems that
that that has not been absorbed by a ton
of talent evaluators who could make Josh
Rosen a top five pick in this year's
draft what do you think about the
conversation of Rosen now that we're a
week away from the draft Trent I think
my big takeaway would be and I'm like
everybody else now that I'm not on TV
I'm just kind of watching as a fan and
listen to my friends talk about people I
respect people I don't respect you know
all the different narratives I'd only
people understand them I think the
people that love them have gotten
understand who he is and appreciate that
type of personality that type of mind
that type of competitor perfectionist
the people they're like oh no entitled
came from money not coachable whatever
these false narratives are kind of like
I was when he was 17 I coached mentally
11 they aren't willing to expand their
brains to say you know not everybody is
like this whoever this is that there's
different makeups of greatness and in
his he needs to be challenged he needs
to be challenged all the time it needs
to be stimulated he is gonna push back
if you just tell him hey do it this way
because this
worked for three other guys he wants to
know the why behind everything I think
that's a good thing I do know this I
know he's fallen more in love with
football over the past couple years than
he loved it before then I think he was
so gifted at it
early on he was so successful that it
just it became part of his identity and
I think the three hard years UCLA and
the three offenses and not winning all
the time you'd won his whole life he won
in tennis he won a John Bosco I mean it
always won now he goes you said he
doesn't win all the time that's hardened
him and made him real uh cat whether he
loves football or whether he loves what
football brings him and two years ago I
said he loves the football brings him
now getting to know him and understand
him more I think he absolutely loves
football so let's take that in two
pieces there for what you just said
starting with what you saw an elite 11
so all of the negatives and red flags
that have been said about Josh Rosen now
used to be viable when he was a 17-year
old I think he would tell you that if he
was sitting right here I'm pretty gone
we just had this conversation in the
airport in Orange County a couple weeks
ago I think he would tell you that yeah
I was immature I was hard-headed I
wasn't that coachable I thought I knew
everything I think he'd be the first
person to anything right and he's not
that guy anymore now is he he's gonna be
a challenge in a good way and I hope I'm
communicating properly this is a good
thing he's gonna challenge the coaches
every single day to bring their a games
he's gonna want to know why he's not
gonna be the guy that sits in the
quarterback room and quarterback coaches
hey Josh on versus coverage when they
roll this safety here I want you to make
this check and throw it over here he's
okay
why what are we accomplishing by doing
that so you're gonna have to bring your
a-game every single day you're gonna
have to you're gonna have to wake up in
the morning as a coach if you're
coaching him and say okay what can I do
today to stimulate him to challenge him
so I get the best out of him because if
I don't if I just bring my normal game
if I just show up to work punch the tick
in come and I'm just gonna get an
average guy I'm just gonna get a guy
that's probably gonna get bored but if I
come in today and I can stimulate them
and I can challenge them with something
and give them
more power more authority of this office
and make it more his you're the sky's
the limit for this kid because from a
talent standpoint a processing
standpoint there's not many that can do
it better so then then here comes the
second part what you're saying sounds
similar to what Jim Moore adds say about
him yeah but what man Morris said that
he's got to be challenged he's gonna ask
why that he needs to make sure you need
to make sure that his his football life
is a challenge otherwise there could be
a problem that that was viewed as a
negative for this problem is boredom its
nothing's gonna go do anything stupid
it's just gonna be boredom it's the same
with a gifted artist or musician right
if they're not stimulated if they're not
creatively stimulated they're just gonna
come out with something there isn't your
board so where do you think the best fit
is for him knowing that you've what you
just said that a coach needs to bring in
coaching staff needs to bring it's a
game and be able to handle the
questioning of their scheme I don't
think the Giants are gonna drop the
quarterback
I'm coming with everybody else okay but
I think that's a great spot for I think
the Jets is a great spot for Jeremy
Bates Jeremy's a smart guys and
intellect he's a thinker he's been
around a lot of great football his his
catalog of information is broad and I
think the city of New York is perfect
for Josh I think he will thrive off the
energy the sophistication the scrutiny
that comes with being in New York I
think it fits perfectly with his
personality and when I'm talking about
challenging him and stimulating him I
think the the fan base in New York will
go crazy over this kid I think he will
endear himself to that particular fan
base I think either New York teams are
grateful so then what about the rest of
the quarterbacks class I we saw Sean
Payton this week say yeah let's tell you
I was a little surprised by the
basically that he's glad that he's not
but woe to the teams that are in the top
five of this draft that need to take a
quarterback because most of this class
saved Arnold might not be successful
while you can say about any class first
of all that may not be successful
because they may go to bad situations
they may get thrown in the fire too soon
they may have their team decimated by
injuries you know there's a lot of maize
from a talent standpoint I'm surprised
Sean said and I respect Sean as much as
any offensive mind in football of the
past 2025 which is why I'm asking you I
disagree wholeheartedly with Sean I
think this is unique quarterback class I
got laughed at 18 months ago when I said
this before I knew they were all coming
out when I was still on TV I said 18
months ago I think this will go down as
a historic draft if they all come out at
the same time I couldn't predict if they
all were going to but now that Donald's
out rosen's al Allen's and Lamar's in
Baker's in I think the Luke there's
tremendous value in a Luke Falk and a
Mason Rudolph I think both those guys
can be in really good pros
I think it's wildly talented I think
it's different
it doesn't fit everybody's eye you know
when you watch tape these days I think
every NFL evaluator struggles with this
and anybody you have on the show will
tell you this it's really hard I can
watch seven college games a baker may
feel and find maybe 25 30 plays that are
what I experienced the NFL or what I
learned how I learned to evaluate NFL
quarterbacks doesn't mean I don't want
to say transferable because there is a
lot of Saturday offense coming into the
NFL
but they just don't make that many
decisions to the line of scrimmage they
don't see that many complex coverages
they don't see a lot of overloads that
create problems with protections they
play at such a pace that they kind of
get these defined looks it's almost like
what I call training camp offense you
know when you go to a training camp and
then FL the only guys will understand
this around FL quarterbacks we think we
should complete 85% of our passes
through an entire training camp because
you're getting pretty much the same
looks you're familiar with the looks at
your own team it's a controlled
environment so you're pretty much
throw-in the ball to number one or
number two every day this can you play
catch that's what college football's
become it's not really quarterback as
much as his catch so it's very I say
this long-winded explanation is simply
explain that I could see why a NFL coach
looks at and goes well I'm not seen
anything that they're gonna do for me
but you did said that five years ago -
you know the game has just changed so
much and there's such a limited
carryover between what they're being
asked to do in college and what they're
doing the NFL that it's it's it's much
harder to evaluate the level of
competency that's what I'm searching for
of these quarterbacks talent isn't the
issue is the level of competency a few
more minutes here with Trent Dilfer your
partner from soul and science on NFL
Network John Brenkus mr. sport signs
himself well the guys will be out here
shortly in our number three actually
here on the Richards and Schilling will
also have Bob Costas so Lamar Jackson
he's just been a fascinating prospect to
say the least
where do you think he fits what do you
think happens with him a week from
tonight in Dallas I think somebody falls
in love with them it's hard not to if
you're a guy that looks to the glass
half-full then you're gonna look at his
is pouring over from a talent standpoint
he is a much better passer than people
give him credit for
he's wildly inconsistent but his good is
extremely good he does want to sit in
the pocket and be a passer only 23% of
his rushing stats in college were
scrambling stats so most of those yards
rushing were designed quarterback runs
so when he drops back he is trying to go
to one to two he can process he can
throw the ball over the field
he's got some technical issues that will
really hold him back unless he fixes
them like what number one is his base
you look at every quarterback the NFL
that's consistent they have a strong
wide base the energy is drawn from the
ground so it's ground up his is really
narrow and so when he strides his stride
frequency and his stride length changes
which changes your release point if it's
from the ground up that's where the
inconsistencies come from but if there's
any issue you want to fix on somebody
easily that's it's one of the easiest
things to fix we fixed with high school
kids all the time right you fix that
alone in one year of him playing the
scout team quarterback and drilling him
every day and teaching him in NFL
offense I think he can get on the field
in year two and be phenomenal I mean I
was a Michael Vick fan real Michael Vick
fan hard not to be right sure
Michael said this this is not my opinion
Michael said this and I agree honor
percent he is light yours better than
Michael was at this point so Mike Latta
pretty darn good career
this kid is much better than Michael
Vick was at this stage you know do you
think the Patriots might be interested
in I mean cuz to me that would be the
most Belichick thing around would be out
and be very for him to basically say
look before I go out the door in my
career I'm gonna totally reinvent myself
the minute Brady decides to leave I'm
gonna reinvent this entire offense watch
me that would be I've not thought about
that
that way that's actually really good
I'll tell what I think if I'm the paint
now again pills you know throw up some
more football than Oliver no sure to me
Luke Falk is the perfect guy to draft as
heir apparents Tom Brady who I said he
his the rhythm of his life his mentality
is exactly like Tom's I mean they Luke's
been working out with Tom House in
Southern California the whole time Tom
Brady has he is mimicked everything that
Tom Brady does not just on the field but
off the field this is the most
disciplined human you'll see in college
he's way more talented and people give
him credit for they have the same way of
looking at the game he's a completion
junkie I think him being the heir
apparent to Tom Brady makes more sense
than I've seen anything makes sense in a
long time if if that made any sense
because I was saying and I was like does
that make us Luke Falk to me is if they
want to maintain their current model I
kind of like where you're going reinvent
yourself but the Luke Falk thing to me
when I was around I studied Luke his
entire time at Washington State then
down to watch him work out at Tom house
did him for the song you know testing
for these stolen science pieces it's
almost plug and play they're the same
type at all last one for you and again
you back in our three the the pro side
the story this week that Aaron Rodgers
might be chafing decisions are being
made without consulting him he denies it
he says it's not the case what do you
what do you think is a longtime veteran
quarterback in this league knowing Aaron
as well as you do of what's going on in
Green Bay I won't speak for
if I were Aaron I'd be assessed too I
think he's earned the right to have a
voice and somebody's decision how so
like what would that voice here's the
one thing I learned when I was playing
you have a lot of guys upstairs the
personnel guys decision makers that
think they know what's going on
downstairs but they really don't and
they view everything from a trait kind
of ceiling standpoint Aaron has a unique
ability because he's so smart from a
football standpoint to understand both
sides he understands the talent and what
it takes to be successful the traits it
also understands all the other stuff the
intangible that as you're gonna hear us
next hour talk about the soul part of
the game which is a huge part of it and
it takes them into that type of brain
who actually cares and who is Pro all he
wants is for the Packers to be better
that's his intention I'm assuming why
wouldn't you take his input why wouldn't
you want one more resource to lean on
but what does that again the question
about it has been what does that for
well in what form does the does the
resource intake take do did you give
them a choice between Jordan out like an
actual personnel decision you got and I
think you empower him to be part of the
conversation isn't he have to win the
argument but empower and to let him be
part of the conversation why wouldn't
and if you have a good reason if you're
the GM and you want to cut Jordy Nelson
at least hear me out where his stay at
where's value lays with me the guy
touching the ball every single snap now
if you want to give me an argument of
how it affects salary cap aging one get
rid of him before the down years
whatever the argument is great you're
the boss but at least hear me out as the
guy the Suffragette they're not just
quarterbacks they're they're the
captains of the ship every decision
you're making upstairs isn't worth squat
if the guy in the ball doesn't have the
buy-in so every time that you're making
a decision that affects the quarterbacks
buy-in you're actually hurting the team
trial format you're the best
Trent Dilfer and John Brenkus soul in
science on NFL Network we will talk
about that next hour with
Bob costis as well we'll wrap up our
number two in a moment the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience